welcome back to the Jenna and Julian
podcast am I like good am i all set you
sound you sound great I know yeah
welcome back to the Jenna and Julian
podcast where we talk over the [ __ ] we
want
and instead of just putting on Ustream
we decided to make it a thing that
existed by itself so that you could
watch it some other time but we just sit
here and drink and [ __ ] hang out and
that's what it and we got you stream up
I don't know whatever this you stream
this [ __ ] you stream and podcast is
brought to you by [ __ ] no one to you
we don't play by any rules and [ __ ] the
rules it's brought to you by our broken
light over there yeah [ __ ] that light
man [ __ ] alright whatever
what do you want to talk about today
Julian I don't know I think it's it's
worth mentioning that probably like an
hour ago Kermit was in the living room
and I was over here setting up and Jenna
said it's coming from here so I like run
over to see what comer was doing and he
was we wanna my mom I think when she
went my mom went to Italy or something
and she brought back this little doggie
shirt that says Italia but it's like for
Kermit it's really tight on him it makes
him look like he's busting out of it and
he hates clothing to start with like he
hates every piece of clothing we try to
put on him he was using his nose - like
nudge it in the corner of this like
basket so we can never find it and
that's what he does like he tries to
hide his clothes did you upload a video
on your channel it is on my channel
there's a video of him hiding his
turtleneck yeah he takes his nose that
he just pokes relentlessly if you see
him he's just like poking his face in
there as hard as you can over and over
and over again and then you'll be like
what is he doing you go look and it's
like a shirt but I've only ever seen him
doing with the turtleneck but I would
start dying laughing because he's doing
it to another shirt like he's just
trying to hide all the clothes he
doesn't have to wear them it's just like
the funniest thing ever that he knows
that that's the one way he can get out
of where he's hiding it it's so sad
because Kermit has like no fur no body
fat like we live in Los Angeles so it's
not particularly cold he was much colder
when I lived with him in Boston but like
he's definitely the type of dog that
would
should appreciate like a warm shirt or
sweater and instead he just freaks the
[ __ ] out and hates it and then he just
demands that he be like on like in my
shirt or wherever I am all the time like
there's no doubt that he's cold he just
doesn't want to get warm by that method
he wants you to put him in your shirt or
wrap him up it's weird man it's funny
though he's so good I loved when he was
doing that like a woodpecker I know if
you watch this on the YouTube channel
you gotta let me know if your dog has
any like weird quirks like that if they
do something funny cuz there's dogs are
weird like dogs are [ __ ] they have so
much personality oh my god so [ __ ]
weird I'm very excited I'm getting an
Italian Greyhound maybe by the time you
watch this I might have her but I'm
really excited to see like what kind of
quirks she'll have like how her
personality will be there no it's gonna
be goofy and I'm just our kids are like
a box of chocolates you never know if
you're gonna get a raspberry one my
favorite yeah you buy that raspberry
really expecting it you're expecting
fudge or cream and there's a fruit
inside that surprise just kidding
there's no dessert here we're giving you
isn't that a perfect analogy for a puppy
you're expecting fudge except you get up
fruit like one thing worse would be like
broccoli filled chocolate but right I
mean raspberries up tasty like salted
broccoli chocolate I'm never eating
broccoli again ever
why well cuz I just dyed it down and all
I ate was like greens and I hate every
single green I hate I hate it really
it's like when I have to eat it I hate
it
like the way I was forcing I was like I
don't know if you saw me but I was like
taking mouthfuls of spinach dry like
I'll get snacky and I'd be like okay
spinach times your problem
sounds like your problem it's all my
problems that's why I'm talking about so
earlier when we were setting up the
Ustream and you were getting your makeup
on I was playing music on my computer
and this was hooked up because I had
unplugged our headphones so they could
hear my voice through the mic
and so through the middle of the song I
would just be like yeah so when you
wrote DJ get leg yeah there's like a
creeper he doesn't even mix he just
creepily like whispers get likes in the
middle of the song teacher get legs just
in case every girl in the club wasn't
creeped out she will be when DJ get legs
gets on the turntables oh my god sorry
you went there first
oh you did creepy job DJ creepy job
that's a good that's a good DJ creepy
job you're listening to DJ cribbage ah
oh it's like our DJ called yells out his
names like it would just be like Oh DJ
oh here comes some Oh get [ __ ]
speaking of DJ Khaled why don't you tell
everyone oh my god about how easy this
is why I'm so glad that we have this
[ __ ] podcast we started this because I
just have so many feelings all the time
about DJ Khaled okay so I follow him on
Instagram I'm pretty into the rap
hip-hop whatever world I like to say
that I keep up a lot better than a lot
of people but so I'm [ __ ] obsessed
with DJ Khaled on instagram and before
anybody takes this like way in the wrong
direction I like him okay I like dj
khaled a lot but he [ __ ] just hits me
in the [ __ ] giggles on his [ __ ]
Instagram because he'll just take like
700 pictures of him like super creepy
like creeping around and then he'll post
like five or six videos in a row of him
being like we the best I changed a lot
like just so [ __ ] weird like he'll be
on a treadmill while he's saying that
like just six videos in a row
I'm out here working man I'm out here on
this bike the perfect impression in
calories
man we the best DJ Calot and they're
like cuts off and you're like what am I
what are you doing DJ callable you gotta
get it
my favorite was he posted a bunch while
he was like in a hot tub he's like I see
you ladies I see you out there talking
about his business he's like oh man we
the [ __ ] best man we worked so hard
and he's just kicked back in a [ __ ]
bubbling jacuzzi and then he was like
here's my deal I just signed this deal
he leans over the [ __ ] jacuzzi like
you know contract or whatever for the
camera for Instagram but the way that he
signed it I don't think I've watched
that video 75 times he know he doesn't
just scribble it would be one thing if
he just scribble a lot of people just
scribble for their hand for their yeah
signature he's like scribbled in a
[ __ ] circle and like went over and
over it and over it like he was signing
this [ __ ] thing for like 10 damn
minutes it was outrageous we the best
sign in a circle sign in a circle side
in a circle like he's a doodling on a
contract and and it should be said that
he's on the treadmill wearing like a
sweat suit like he's this 300-pound man
and he's on a treadmill which is great
but he's wearing a sweat suit and he's
just extra sweaty and then there's that
video where he's like you member that
video he's like he's like he's like
showing off his like his neck like
ligaments he's trying to draw up his
chest but I never had that before I was
like look at me and he does this and
instead of like showing his traps he
like does this when your ligaments come
out of your neck neck so [ __ ] weird
oh car wreck you can't look away you got
to keep looking at Instagram that's no I
love it
no cuz I'll be like outside and Julia
heard me laughing like are you watching
DJ Khaled's yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah it's
definitely guilty dude did you see him
on like SportsCenter or whatever when he
was talking no I was like first take or
something knows when they were with the
people after him yeah right yes and they
were talking about LeBron James oh my
god they were like Hughes like it was
rigged like they did it you know it was
a conspiracy theory that they turned the
a/c off so that LeBron couldn't [ __ ]
play and so the it's you're on a TV show
you know it's not Twitter you don't just
throw out your on the desk
yeah yeah and so he's like no I know
this man like they did that to my boy
LeBron and whoever was interviewing
Steven Naismith yeah it was like oh how
do you know that he's like cuz I got
word on the street the streets told me
you're like alright dude like did does
anyone help you like nobody help nobody
helps him and nobody says no my favorite
part that says hey yeah he is all yes
man around a very part of that whole
interview okay if you haven't seen this
just look it up look up like dj khaled
on SportsCenter my favorite part is like
okay so there's like three or four
anchors like Steven Naismith I don't
even know who they are but they're
talking him right and the interview
starts out like okay he's this you know
he's this DJ he's this music producer
maybe he knows you know a thing or two
and they're talking and then at one
point in the conversation when he
mentions this conspiracy and he starts
sounding like a crazy person you could
see on all three of the anchors face
they collectively were like oh okay yeah
and it's like all at the same time you
see their demeanor just all collectively
switch to like okay let's just survive
this interview and it's really funny but
there's been times like I feel like DJ
Colin and I have gone through a
rollercoaster relationship on Instagram
because there's been times where I'm
like should I [ __ ] don't follow him
because I feel like I'm at some points I
feel like I'm laughing at him yeah but
at other points I'm like totally just
like down with it and think it's amazing
it's quality entertainment but sometimes
I've gone through these like I think I
should just unfollow him because it's
just taking up way too much time and
like a mental focus and energy to follow
- that's so funny how you put that
I feel like Instagram videos for me like
there's such a hit or miss type thing
like if it's just a person talking like
I 99% of the time I'm too awkward or too
like afraid to feel awkward that I'll
watch my Instagram videos all on the
feed on silent because I don't want to
hear the audio I'm afraid I'm just gonna
like cringe and then feel weird
has to take like a lot of interest for
me to like hear an Instagram video with
the sound on I don't disagree with that
I feel like most people do that they
turn their phone off because you're on
you're scrolling through looking at
pictures and all of a sudden like I
follow [ __ ] Taz's angels and like
prostitutes basically and all of a
sudden look like yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] suck your dick for money
oh and then you know some poor person
and in a doctor's office is like excuse
you yeah what are you doing yeah yeah
sorry man [ __ ] Instagram yeah it's
like when you're on vine you turn the
volume on cuz you know what you're
getting is exactly you're signing up for
that you're like okay vine time I'm
gonna listen but if you're like not if
you're like it for me it's like early in
the morning before I'm like coffees in
me or whatever other side I can't hear
some gamble like it's a gamble if I'm
gonna feel this awkward early in the
morning I got a call it a day at like 10
a.m. I gotta go back to bed and just but
like there's uh I'm not gonna mention
who it is there's this kid who's a
family friend or whatever and do you
know the whole deal with Herbalife no
okay no I mean it's
I mean maybe her life is is this well
let me preface it with it's a pyramid
scheme prophecy so I don't know if you
member like Cutco or something like that
yeah it's similar to that but it's um
it's a supplement company yeah my
sister's boyfriend
in high school it worked for Coco yeah
he came to our house I read I read a
post online you know getting a summer
job in Rochester is a little tricky
sometimes it's not really know how to do
yes that's what I wanted working in it
summer camps but I thought that the
application or like the job listing said
Petco like wedding I was like you know
just scrolling and applying to anything
that's a pet home like oh man that
sounds fun yeah and then they called me
and they're like hey someone's up from
Petco a pet coat I'm like yeah I mean
I'd love to come in and I sat there you
know for there for our [ __ ]
orientation slash interview of everyone
and my face is just like I think I'm
lost
yeah anyway just keep good no no that's
yeah it's similar to Cutco it's called
Herbalife I'm sure a lot of people who
are watching this have heard of it it's
a supplement company I mean basically I
don't even know exactly their product
line but I know it's a long lines of
like a protein shake like a meal
replacement shake like a protein bar and
then just like the typical like apparel
from you know and what they do is they
they hire these young teenagers you know
under 20 between like 15 and 20 to be
part of teams they call them teams which
is already a bad sign like team I don't
know like team for for a for something
in both team we don't have to pay you
like more than ya know but the team well
that's the thing like the teams are they
sound cooler than just like you're a
sales associate
they sound cooler than that okay and
another thing is you know as you start
recruiting and all they do is recruit
they're like who wants to be part of my
sales team like that's the coolest thing
for them is to recruit and have a better
team which is a telltale sign of a
pyramid scheme you're recruiting people
yeah and like Verve and all these I mean
it's just it's so if you know the signs
which it doesn't take a lot to know it's
so blatantly out there it's such a
pyramid scheme and I went on a huge
tangent but there's a kid on Instagram
who all of his Instagram videos are him
like you know I better myself today like
I'm part of this team who wants to be
the next part of my team and then it
shows like he shows like pictures of
like him and a limo on this like sales
trip and it's all like oh my this is
like [ __ ] Enron this is a joke like
they are gonna take you for such a ride
and then you're you're you look like
such a fool right now like I there was a
post on reddit about Herbalife and a
bunch of people were commenting like
I've lost friends over Herbalife like
some of my friends got into Herbalife
and now they are just so goddamn
unbearable and they're so into this
clearly just [ __ ] scam that I can't
even be around them anymore it's like
crazy cult it's very cold it sounds like
CrossFit it's very different than Christ
I'm kidding it's just crazy though how
scary it is to look at that and be like
you were a perfectly able human being
and you don't see this
yes that's I don't know what I feel like
as I've gotten older and you see like
what people turn into and what they
invest their time and energy and it's
like I'm sure there's plenty of people
that look at me and are just like
cringing like well this is horrible like
what the [ __ ] is she doing but at least
nobody's telling me what to do I'm not
working for anyone
recruit not I'm not recruiting yeah I I
go to bed at night feeling confident
that like I'm doing something that's fun
and funny coming from a good place but
like the whole when you see people and
you don't really know what to say to
them seriously that's you would need
like he would need to do something to
you personally in order for you to ever
say something did I mean because it's
just not worth it like hey man this is
your friend Julian just want to let you
know that your life's getting really
weird yeah he was a closer friend I
would I would have to say what would you
do if it was your best friend
okay I mean you staged some sort of an
intervention you have to at some points
here's the thing our podcast is brought
to you by it sounds so ridiculous
Herbalife intervention but this shit's
[ __ ] for real man and if I first of
all if I had a friend that I could call
like I tell him Sarah but first of all
I'd be so [ __ ] scared that someone I
picked to be my best friend is like is
like getting caught up in something like
[ __ ] this I mean you gotta be
questioned how smart my best friend dude
that's it that's it but I mean you know
I followed this kid I'm talking about I
unfollowed on my Instagram because I
used to vol him cuz he would post like
work out or whatever and he was just a
family friend like I followed him and
then it became so like all too much yeah
and then it's just like it's like a car
wreck you're like oh this guy's ruining
his life he's ruining his [ __ ] time I
can't even watch this there's no but
there's no it's like there's no getting
through to him right now
I mean I'm really I don't follow like
everyone that I know cuz I don't I don't
I don't know I follow some my closest
friends on Instagram yeah but like you
follow one people more often than I do
because I just don't really notice me go
scroll through and just really gotta
[ __ ] whatever yeah like nobody's ever
really pissed me off enough to unfollow
them
good point yeah they have to strike that
nerve
what's the nerve that they have to
strike in order feed on and follow them
Twitter Instagram Facebook anything for
me yeah that's a good question well
here's one if it's a weightlifting
person I fall because I go on the
popular page with their explore page and
I anyone who I like see is a wit let's
explore
so I find people anymore it's different
it's a different experience I like we
can get to that in a sec there's the
things there are things I like about
things I don't like that but one thing
for sure is if I'm following a new
weightlifting or maybe sometimes
CrossFit person and they slam one bar
onto the ground
on top no no question about it if you
slam the bar onto the ground I hate that
I don't get it what do you mean okay
clean jerk oh it's a PR it's so juvenile
it's like you spiking a football except
it's like two 300 pounds
yeah you really dick the whole sport is
like such a gentlemen's like basic like
pure sport and you're gonna [ __ ] take
it to the level looking like a giant you
also just timeout for a second you also
need to clarify that within your sport
bumper plates it's acceptable to drop
them that is good absolutely because you
you can like let them go because you
couldn't hurt yourself if you are
setting it down if you lift it up the
pump the bumper plates are rubbery
they're bouncy for a reason for you to
be able to do that so we're not talking
about just dropping the weeds we're
talking about blatantly throwing it down
and then being like yeah [ __ ] yeah I'm
an alpha male ya know that's a good
clarification point okay anyways the
sport
if someone slams the bar well yes that's
it that's your line to unfollow that
yeah I mean it's proper technique to
have a bar all the way above your head
loaded with weight to drop it all the
way to the ground people comment on my
Instagram and say oh you just drop the
bar like a douche no I'm not going in
and getting full metal cast iron plates
dropping them on like on wood floor at a
gym like this is the the sport that's
how you do it it's the technique what
I'm talking about is when you hit a big
lift or you're really happy about it and
though you're
way above your head whether it's a
snatch or whatever and you yell and then
you you lift your feet about off the
ground and then you like propel the way
down as fast but no it looks like a
looks like an ape
you look like an eight yeah and I don't
know what it like there are some lifters
that are world-class lifters that do
that sometimes and I just don't know
what it is I can't deal with it makes me
so angry
like they slam it on the ground it's so
disrespectful like I don't even want to
get it all right that's one of my things
all unfollow someone instantly if they
do instantly I I'm trying to think of
other things that I wouldn't follow
people for like I never I like never get
that far
yeah look if someone personal like I've
definitely unfriended someone on
Facebook if I only can't stand then like
I have literally cannot [ __ ] stand
that yeah but I don't even go on
Facebook enough to ever get to that
point yeah have you ever owned followed
someone cuz you just didn't like what
they were posting anymore yeah I think
that's the TV turned off I go turn off
if you want him I'll talk for a second
yeah good all right he's got two TVs is
[ __ ] annoying this podcast brought to
you by we left the [ __ ] TV on um
yeah an Instagram Twitter though a
Twitter I think I've never unfollowed
anybody like ever people are like you
unfollowed me I'm like no I didn't I
know it didn't unfollow you because I've
never unfollowed anybody ever like what
the [ __ ] yeah I think it's just a ploy
so that I'll follow them yeah but even
if they just said can you follow me I
would follow them yeah I see it follow
everyone yeah that I can it really
allows you to follow a thousand people a
day which is annoying
now you're awesome about it you follow a
lot of people yeah but like you
unfollowed me I'm like [ __ ] no I didn't
you tell me I'm a liar no Twitter does
these things though they aren't
following follow people for you like
it's happened to me before I yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah where I clicked like
a long time ago I would follow someone
and then I'd go back to their profile
months later and I wouldn't be following
them yeah that's definitely happened
multiple times multiple times and it's
really awkward because people are like
what did I do
and you're like nothing better yeah I
don't know I mean aside from obnoxious
things in sport and weightlifting
I don't really follow people that much I
don't follow too many people
I don't follow away living people follow
my friends not too much else yeah I know
some people like if I if I was given the
time and to really weed through that I
would unfollow only because they're just
like way too much on their own kool-aid
yeah I hate people that hashtag rise &
grind and then tell you [ __ ]
everything that they're doing I hate
people that hashtag like doing big
things and like my future is so amazing
like hashtag big things I just can't
stand it Jamie no absolutely I just I
feel like you know it's wonderful to be
proud of yourself for accomplishments
for doing things we're all happy for you
but let you motivate when you tell me
like some of these people have known
since early college when you tell me
like everyday hashtag rise & grind doing
big things and you still live at home
with your parents I mean at what point
are you just gonna stop hash tagging
rise & grind you're not grinding it's
it's it's writing your coffee is it my
you're grinding and parents coffee it's
a minor some are [ __ ] 27 years old
like grow up man well I think it's just
it's it's a minor delusion you know I
mean they actually loose maybe there's
some other issues also well yeah I mean
it's like if you're living at home
you're that old you're being supported
you're being supported and you're you're
you think posting that as a hashtag
blessed our blessed that's my favorite
one I think that that can be used in
really great like a tie I've used that
before I forget one but hashtag blessed
can be really funny yeah again ya know
the whole rising grad thing the whole
big things come in or or haters can't
get me down like it's just all right
come on just stop it's only cute if it's
like I don't know I'm trying to think of
somebody like Little Debbie George you
know who well Debbie was on [ __ ] I
love her I love crayon I love that whole
[ __ ] crew you know I do yeah what's
the other one be nasty nasty I the
feeling she was gonna be part of us
love that but like just Little Debbie
can do no wrong in my eyes so what if
she says you know [ __ ] hashtag [ __ ]
haters and sure it like that like I that
doesn't bother these exceptional well
there's people like her she's not
obnoxious she's really doing her own
[ __ ] thing and you can't even hate on
her because she has incredible hair all
the time she just goes so hard yeah and
I [ __ ] love her well great she's I
mean I I've you show explaining that
there can be an exception to rise in
grind
absolutely and [ __ ] you well absolutely
I mean of course there's an exception
because there's got to be someone that
all these [ __ ] dopes are copying
right there doing this thinking that
they're looking like someone who they
know right they're like oh I'm gonna use
it that example be nastier whoever
they're like oh you know they're
successful they have this many followers
they have this many albums whatever they
hashtag rise & grind maybe if I do that
you know I could be viewed the same way
but it's very saying it's a learned
behavior well it's it's it's the someone
that they look up to is using that
language in an effective way to make
someone think that that should also
describe them yeah you're idolizing
someone in the way they act on social
media so you think if you act that way
then you're gonna cut all the corners
and just kind of become that person or
where they are yeah I don't know it's
almost like if you like follow pro
athletes on on social and right and then
and you you seek out of their tendencies
and then you start copying them and but
you're a high school JV player it's like
yeah you're writing the same thing
you're not LeBron you're doing exactly I
mean that picture is great put it
side-by-side with the bronze I'm telling
you that is a great shot like yeah
that's a great picture but do I like it
if it's funny I don't like it if it's
serious it's never ironic it's always
like I agree with you speaking of high
school sports
there were like how many kids did you
[ __ ] because we were both athletes we
played baseball softball all the way
through college
I did three sports although one of them
I'm not sure you buddy consider a sport
I did diving bowling in south Oh [ __ ]
whatever whatever we gotta go Bullitt
what's worth did you play baseball just
baseball in high school for JV and
varsity yeah yeah but there's [ __ ]
there's always kids that it's not funny
they're not looking excited to play
they're just on their own [ __ ] dick
they're just on their own dick and it's
so [ __ ] obnoxious and I am just
thankful that when I was in high school
I didn't have to have some online way
where I needed to see any more of their
[ __ ] life yeah than them at practice
you're so [ __ ] full of yourself all
the time and I hate you as it is I would
[ __ ] be furious if I had to see them
on my newsfeed and I had to follow them
because they're my teammate I'd rather
not [ __ ]
I'd rather [ __ ] not where are you
talking about the people who who like
ride the bench but then they tweet
pictures of their jerseys okay check out
the check out this fresh Jersey it's got
my name on it although I just rode the
bench for three straight double headers
oh my god no that's not what I'm talking
about
I'm talking about kids that think that
they're they're actually really great
they're the best in the state and
they're not do you know what I mean like
you you have no state titles you're
you're not going to college on a
scholarship
you're not doing anything like that
you're just you need to [ __ ] get a
reality check it's obnoxious it's kind
of obnoxious especially when everyone
else in the entire world especially
everyone else in the entire team is
looking at you like you're a fool right
but I feel like those are the people
that I can think of in my brain that
would post a picture of themselves next
to LeBron and be like hashtag we're the
same person
hashtag on the road to greatness
greatness [ __ ] please yeah [ __ ] please
there's no egos and bowling I'll tell
you that if you could kindly hop off
your own dick nice ball eggs an
incredible sport because bugging
everybody's just there to kick it yeah
Bowlings fun I've never played
competitively obviously yeah it was a
great sport
it was eat you
you'd be me like in one game she's
really good she didn't have my ball all
my shoes let's not forget about that
what's a artist without their tools
you're right sorry
I be sure the plastic ball you beat me
one [ __ ] time but I had my ball my
ball
game over I should not come on it it has
my name on it my ego there's there's two
trophies over there that say most ideal
teammate that's pretty awesome that's a
great throw the most ideal teammate
isn't that nice though but that's the
type of sport that balling is you get an
award like obviously we would get awards
for being good but like I would sort of
build the road I wasn't I wasn't that
good and uh you get a [ __ ] award for
most ideal teammate I like what a sport
man like how they worded it most ideal
team I mean most of the well that's was
when baseball high school whatever
literally any time you got there was
like the MVP there was like the slugger
there was like the pitcher award and
those were all like Golden Gloves yeah
those were all like distinct you have a
skill and that's where I get this wart
and then there was the coach's award and
I got that [ __ ] I got that once my
brother got that a couple times I think
but it's basically the coach is like hey
man you suck I feel bad for you why
don't you take this trophy and then
that's what it was but the way they
worded most ideal teammate would have
been so much more constructive most
ideal teammate that means you are the
one everyone wants to know you're
basically the MVP without even being the
MVP great waited brilliant I was the
captain you know not that great I'm not
offering some big scores for the team
over here but I'm really good at [ __ ]
making everybody else happy and have a
great time and I got rewarded for that
which I thought was incredible in a way
that made me feel really good
that's a 16 year old girl absolutely
yeah definitely plus it also helps when
you get an award like that you can't
help but be like yeah [ __ ] yeah thanks
friends five of us on a team yeah look
yeah I don't even have a bowling team in
high school that's really cool me me me
you me you crazy
praise we do this all the time like
whenever
you get excited about something you're
like oh I did this or whatever and me
and really don't feel like you you
praise and the other person will be like
me me no not like that so you do it like
a little like self affirmation chain
like me me me aka we act like children
and it's awesome yeah but that's unlike
[ __ ] posting your own picture next to
LeBron yeah because it's joke it's a
joke we're doing it ironically
you you probably cuz there's a camera oh
how bye yeah yeah I'll bite ear
I think there should have been word
called the most legs that got the most
legs you know what in college I want an
award when you're talking about it sort
of like at what I'm listen oh I thought
you're making a face like something bad
was happening I did make a weird face I
got an award called the glue award would
you sort of [ __ ] but yeah it's not a
plaque it's somewhere I think it's over
there but it was basically like you know
when the [ __ ] hits the fan you're the
only one [ __ ] holding the dick
together god yeah that's crazy
yeah the glue award yeah what if they
gave awards to like kids and families
with like parents who argued and they're
like the glue award every time your
parents argue you make them happy again
here's the glue award oh my god I don't
know why I said that it's true though
like I felt like that a little bit at my
brother's wedding
don't do that yes you did that's exactly
a good brothers you know a little bit
busy that day getting married and stuff
I feel like my family has a you know not
any more than any other family just some
relatives that might not get along like
I'm sides of families and that sort of
thing yeah yeah things that happen
before you were born or [ __ ] whatever
whatever and that it's sort of your job
because you're the you're the child
you're the peacemaker like everyone
looks forward to seeing you like I'm
almost [ __ ] 30 years old but somehow
I'm still like the baby like this little
young
and our family on my family it's all
like we were sort of the youngest I have
one cousin who's like twenty-one but
like there's little kids and uh so yeah
it's sort of like my responsibility
because my brother was you know busy
getting married so you know sort of walk
around and make sure that all my family
was like [ __ ] happy yeah not at each
other's throats and yeah that's what I
felt like I should have won the glue
Award for my brother's wedding well you
did it was an unofficial award
they just sent you a stick of glue in
the mail here's here's here's some of
you you're glue thanks for keeping their
relatives entertained
oh you're welcome I remember like yeah
you were like you know I'm really sorry
I couldn't tell you this but I needed to
be there yeah I needed to focus my
energy and I'm bigger and better and
greater things greater good
you know wouldn't have been a fun
wedding for you to be at because like I
don't see my family like aside from my
mom and that sort of thing like I don't
see my family coz they live in Rogers
Massachusetts so I needed to go no no I
mean I understood hey hey okay
PSA if you ever decide to get legs and
become a genius and put crispy little
bits of bacon in your mac and cheese
just know that you're never gonna be
able to eat mac and cheese by itself
ever again because I do that last night
and I can't eat mac and cheese so so
last night I went out with Tyler Oakley
and we haven't had like an opportunity
really to hang out together that much
we've we have known who each other are
obviously and say hello when we're
whatever we're in the same event YouTube
FanFest Sydney Singapore of VidCon
playlist that sort of thing but like we
haven't really gotten to like spend time
to hang out and get to know each other
which is something for me personally is
really important before I like collab or
like do anything like that I needed to
like know them a little bit as a human
being and even just to know if I like
want to go down that road of friendship
because I think just cuz you have the
same job doesn't necessarily mean that
you should just be [ __ ] best friends
but I really
hangout Tyler get to know him and we had
a [ __ ] fantastic time looks like we
hit it off [ __ ] coolest dude and um I
was telling Julian like you know Tyler
wanted to go have some drinks and I
texted Tyler like should I get an uber
or not he was like meet me for a drink
I'm like gonna be so you know texting
Julian like oh you know we're just
having another drink and then before you
know it we're like three drinks and
we're going to see someone sing at
another bar I'm like ah you know what
this is just it's beyond me in this way
but we had a great [ __ ] time and then
I was texting Julian's I hadn't eaten
dinner she skipped dinner because she
got home from work I was like okay time
to get done app I gotta go soon
and I was like starving and like getting
too drunk cuz I hadn't eaten feeling
every ounce of alcohol and uh so I get
home I like 2:30 in the morning or
something because it was far away and uh
I had just fallen asleep like you dress
very before Julian had made me a pot of
macaroni and cheese and I ran into the
room was like Joanne like wake up I'm
sorry I stayed out so late I got drunk
like a drunk II and he was like hey I
made you some macaroni and cheese like
you wanna except there's a surprise in
it it's crispy and I'm like what do you
mean means I go in there and I open this
[ __ ] pot of macaroni and cheese and
there's [ __ ] bacon in it there's
pieces of [ __ ] bacon and macaroni and
cheese it was a nice is like the purple
box
yep the white cheddar shells we got I
thought I'd died and gone to heaven
it was so good that I really don't think
that I can ever just eat macaroni and
cheese without ladies you can't go back
I'm sorry
good it's salty it's crispy oh yeah and
it should be noted that this bacon was
pepper crusted bacon so there's pepper
on the outside of the cut and I spent
like I was like I was like a nice little
housewife that night I was I spent like
a good ten minutes chopping him up I was
like nice fine pieces and then I crisped
them on the pan
and then let him soak in that little and
little grease and then when the her pop
of mac and cheese was done I just toss
it in there and then I was like all
right she's gonna be huh
well cuz I mean I'm not gonna let you
tell me I'm starving I'm starving
getting so drunk and not do anything
like I couldn't go give you food I had
to but um you know fast forward to the
point we're trying to make you eat bacon
in your mac and cheese you'll never eat
bacon not in your mac and cheese good
sentence Thanks you see that's a first
example of how that goes that was
totally natural that would happen if the
camel if ever there's someone that you
care about in your life whatever they
say you you go go work good we
complement each other's burbs we say
cool bird thanks Mimi me I know I was
like we were laughing like if there's
ever a small human around and like I
would I can't stop saying good burp like
I said it to Ryan Higa at Maria's house
I said it to Ryan hey guys
he said thanks all right oh my god I
can't believe I just [ __ ] said I know
because you can't stop saying it was a
little kid around the poor thing would
just think that burping is so wonderful
because we're always cool yeah when go
burp we say it to the dogs to when they
like have that weird burp sound good gag
Kermit yeah good scarf down of my food
and gag good you're good dog just go
hide some more of your clothes and steal
our food and your great dog I love
Kermit I'm gonna get my own mile [ __ ]
and she's gonna be mine I'm gonna eat
her like a peach out don't you I'm just
saying are you just raising her to get
her fat plump her up that's so [ __ ]
how are you gonna cook her I'm gonna eat
raw like a peach Julian all right this
is all a joke everyone I'm gonna eat my
dog
God God I could just lick barbecue sauce
off of her except it's too sweet all
right little so stop while we're ahead
with this we can cut that part out we
need to say brought to you by people who
eat dogs I know you have so many great
sponsors including cannibals sponsored
by my empty bottle of cider empty empty
look for your look you look at your
local store for empty and you could have
a good empty I was like you Tyler last
night I think he's doing a podcast too
and he's like do you have a sponsor or
like what
maybe middle someday when we send the
woman know how to act at if the sponsor
wants to sponsor someone who acts like a
child and doesn't act right yeah [ __ ]
take that no those are the whole thing
with when I was you know listening to
people I never really listened to people
and I just never want to do anything
that so Mattel is that a sentence like a
standalone sentence I never really
listened to people sorry no [ __ ] you too
I'm [ __ ] with you sorry it was a good
opportunity I'm sorry go ahead girl girl
but someone not in a position of power
but in a position of like trying to help
me yeah was like you know have you ever
considered just like not swearing in
your videos because I think it would be
like more brand friendly now mind you I
don't do any [ __ ] brand deals because
I just can't like I just feel really
conflicted about it and there's lots of
people that do like an amazing job doing
it but it's definitely a skill dude I
mean to integrate a brand naturally in a
way that's not doesn't seem like
commercial it's got to align with you as
a person right but I'm just terrible at
it and still to this day I've never
really had an opportunity where I felt
like something was a good fit because
I'm just I just can't I'm just bad at it
you know I'm [ __ ] I'm just bad but uh
yeah I was thinking about that when
Tyler was like do you have a sponsor and
I was like no like we're just gonna do
it lies I guess like why would I need a
sponsor like [ __ ] like I don't know
anything I told you already
started the job I really think about
podcast I don't think about anything
yeah I'm just like all we want to do is
record our [ __ ] conversations having
any ways but I can only imagine that it
would be the same thing about anything
as it is with my youtube channel where
it's like well maybe if you didn't swear
and talk about such like horribly like
inappropriate things sometimes maybe
someone would see really what I mean and
that's a thing like if I gave a [ __ ]
maybe I would [ __ ] I don't know be
good at that [ __ ] but I know it's not
even about that it's like give a [ __ ]
well it's like Jenna as a person and
Julian you know now I'm involved in this
like officially as a person we don't
like I mean there's there's no we don't
have any urge to act you know as normal
or as confined as most other people on
you know in this sort of realm and if
you know if say a company comes along
and they're like their whole thing is
like no-holds-barred like we want to be
raw and we want to sponsor your podcast
because you're real we don't care you
swear all the power to you no I mean
that makes sense but it's like if
coca-cola was like all right well
sponsor you if you don't say this you
don't say it's just like okay that
doesn't make sense
don't do that that's one of the thing
that the people don't always realize
unless you're like in the world
yeah is that you know the more money
that they're offering you or the more
money that they're they want to invest
more fine print yes
the more they want to control what your
content is which I just I feel like it's
easier for me to just be like nope can't
do it sorry like I don't even know what
I'm doing half the time on Wednesdays
you know I don't have enough foresight
to really [ __ ] make videos happen or
I could tell them you know they want it
at the a week or more a month I had in
advance like what you're gonna be doing
and I'm like dude I'm [ __ ] out like
do you trust me or do you not trust me
sounds like you don't trust me therefore
I don't want to do it oh thank you
seriously and I'm I'm convinced like you
know in a hypothetical situation if you
were to take say a sponsor that did want
to control you and in a video where you
were sponsored by them and you didn't
even mention that you were sponsored
people would be able to tell because of
how you're acting it's like you're so
one way so if anything were to affect
that it's any single fan of Jenna
okay right away something's off yeah no
people have a threshold for it - like
that I feel like there's a lot of
youtubers and people in you know vine or
that sort of thing that do brand deals
which i think is fantastic because they
can do it in a way that makes sense for
them and is not offensive to their
audience but there's definitely a
threshold for an audience member before
you're like alright dude like are you
gonna [ __ ] make anything except for
commercials now that's what they are I
get it you gotta make your money and go
on with your bad self
yeah in order to do it and for in order
for you to keep existing for us because
I'm selfish we want to see you like
especially vine I'm like I get it
because there's no there's no Adsense
there's no way for that monetize you
know I understand why they do brand
deals and why they have to be integrated
and they have to do them as sort of flat
rates and they do need that I imagine
like those people would like
family-friendly content like they're not
just giving money and you know asking to
put their brand on something that might
be like really [ __ ] up but I get it I
respect it but sometimes I feel like it
goes too far you mean where you're like
well what happened to just use a person
and then I think it breaks that barrier
of trust when they do it like I don't
trust you anymore I thought you were
real and what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] I
think it's a good point you know yeah
and I think people try to pull a lot of
fast ones
they're like alright you know if I take
Hanes and I start wearing Hanes
undershirts and I say a couple times the
video they won't notice and then it
builds from that and to something else
and it's like soon enough you're just a
walking commercial well I mean in my
experience at least for YouTube they
they want like more than one video you
know they'll offer you you know whatever
for a video to do it but then sometimes
they'll be like we want you to mention
it in three videos over the next two
weeks if you're like our main channel
yeah that does make any sense does that
even upload or they'll be like you know
you need to tweet six times Facebook
post six times [ __ ] and I'm like cool
alright fine
you know what let's [ __ ] negotiate
can I do them all at 5:30 in the morning
all in a row because [ __ ] you like I'm
just bad at it yeah
I'm bad at it because I just because
you're real and that's not it's it's not
in your it's not your kind of nature to
do that yeah but sometimes it's good
sometimes people I don't I don't agree
at all I think every single you know
rule like this has an exception there's
always a situation where it makes sense
like I said like if there was a sponsor
that way you know wanted nothing to
change wanted only to just you be you
then it wouldn't it would be more you
know sense sensible they say that though
in the beginning and then they decide
further along the the process that they
would really you know like you to do it
differently yeah and okay you always got
to keep control that's what you if any
if anyone can learn from anyone and see
you you can learn from Jenna to keep
control don't ever give up control yep
well done as soon as we get those shirts
I'm gonna wear one on the podcast you do
I worry you're what are the shirt to
work today I got a guy I got a couple
looks people [ __ ] cute it's a really
good-looking shirt and I'm telling you
like it's all about the shirt like an
American Apparel like the way it fits in
your bar it just looks so much better
than like cheap shirts you can tell
right away when people are wearing cheap
shirt
sorry tangent ya know we were talking
about [ __ ] district lines
I like district lines they're nice
people to clarify those are the people
who make your merch or sell your
birthday yeah but like I don't [ __ ] I
don't do merge to [ __ ] make money do
not I mean yeah do them because people
want them to exist and then we try and
make them to exist but they kind of just
the whole process just sort of takes so
long where I know for a fact because the
previous work experience that it could
take a [ __ ] day and they could be out
do you know what I mean it's kind of
annoying when I'm like hey it's Jenna
I'd really like a shirt that says get
legs because I know like three people
that want them yeah
so I want them to exist in the bag
alright and they'll send me over all
these fonts I'm like no just just please
just say just get legs that's it like
don't overcomplicate this one
[ __ ] get legs like a bold regular
font that's it done can we make it and
then it's like well you approve it and
then we make them and then we [ __ ]
take forever and then we suck our own
dicks and then we suck your dick dicks
dicks whole lot nonsense
could be a lot easier I mean it could
but I don't know I just want to show you
this those get legs really bad waiting
selfish it's gonna be that woman again I
mean who knows but want me yeah I want a
black one I love black t-shirts black is
my also on a black one look we don't
even know what colors are gonna come in
here all right you know what enough I'm
taking control tomorrow I'm calling
district lines I'm gonna give them a
piece of my mind
excuse you we need shirts that say get
legs or else we're gonna write them on a
doorstep now tomorrow
explain what get legs means to anyone
that is watching this and doesn't know
I'm pretty sure it originates from golf
where you hit the ball or you put the
ball and it stops I know it yeah yeah no
I know from baseball but I'm pretty sure
it's starting golf where you hit the
ball and it's slowing down you're like
get leg you're telling the ball to get
legs like if it were to get legs and
walk a little further because you want
to go further I learned it in baseball
Jenna learned it in softball where you
hit the ball and it's like almost over
the fence or it's almost somewhere and
you're like get legs balls yeah you are
yelling at the ball get legs or if
you're running the bases
get legs get legs you're stealing a base
someone's trying to throw eggs get legs
but recently I just decided to start
saying it again to everything and then
get legs I love it it's just such a
great saying and then we used it in one
of your videos after that where we were
like get here get it like in the slow
blink video where you get legs you can't
explain it you just gotta go watch that
video like make sense of it even then
you want to understand it because it's
funny and ridiculous but ya get legs I
love get legs your legs I love Sarah met
yet will you please then get the on the
eggs we should make another shirt where
it's like a watering pitcher and then
just Kermit like three people would buy
it right well we would just have to send
one to Sonya Sonya needs one I mean that
picture of GSP I mean Sonya said we got
me yeah we're talking about people that
are like super hardcore internet friends
yeah and they're just [ __ ] in on all
the [ __ ] like Sonya is one of those
people yeah we would need to send Sonya
a shirt that shows what they are Sarah
meant so ridiculous but it's awesome
that we have like a really small group
of people who get every single joke that
comes that right yeah I want to okay for
for example I want to clarify more
watery or Sarah Matt comes from they
uploaded a video and you know I try my
best to read as many comments as I can
for a while on the actual YouTube
channel it gets a little overwhelming
when you're looking at all of your
social medias and you're like so many
things to read right now um but someone
like obviously some of the most
ridiculous I would say sentences as
comments come on YouTube videos yes
you're just like what [ __ ] planet are
you on
are you okay like how do you even
survive as a human yeah so this one
comment said is Kermit but it was
spelled CER M et like you got person
thought in their brain Kermit okay
see er m80 done is Kermit next okay if
you wrap your head around [ __ ] that
and that's not even the first time that
I've seen someone spell carpet like that
see er any tea what is your brain doing
today
are you alright after that it said is
serum it going to grow that's it that's
all the common said and I just had like
the giggles that day and I just was like
in tears laughing I was [ __ ] dying
because it we turned it into this weird
voice that we do for current sometimes
where they come Karen we it's like what
our this you know yeah um and so I'm
like oh it's Kermit going to grow like
we were doing it as the person
commenting like um hello there I have
been watching this channel for quite
some time
I feel like your dog Sara met he been
around the same size for quite some time
and he's not growling I'm very concerned
is he going to growl and then we we
would just say it back and forth like
have you been feeding your Sara Matt
have you been watering him and making
sure that he gets plenty of sunlight
because I'm very concerned if he's going
to grow or not it's the funniest thing
in the whole world so [ __ ] there's
some people have made these pictures
that are like just you know watering can
with Kermit in it and so do you put a
[ __ ] like one of those bubbler those
little automatic like watering thing
watering water and like the Kermit toy
and it's like I'm watering my snare
myself and it's just like such a small
ridiculous joke but the way we built off
of it is just so funny water
yeah our Sam Matt I just couldn't get
over like what that person was thinking
it's funny enough to start a whole genre
of humor which is what it did I don't
there's plenty of funny comments on
YouTube there's fun ones that are way
funnier than that I just for some reason
that day just had the sillies this is
like as Sam it's going to end grow are
you Arthur in your sermons are you
giving appropriate maths right there it
needs to be growing is Sarah math is
very under under sighs you know if I
could animate
how how to take care of your Sarah Matt
okay first you take your Sarah map and
you need to make sure he's there in the
very high through m-- and then that pie
throw him he's in the hot bed and then
you give him some check-in to make sure
that the end growls and then you rot
there him and you put them outside in
the sunlight and at the end of the day
you put him in the incubator and make
sure every grouse thank you
all right you know what enough we're
giving you our material that's gonna be
in a video when when Jenna learns how to
animate someday someday you figure out
what to do with it I just want it to be
a thing it's a great it's a great
[ __ ] joke are you going to wat do you
Sarah meant I just love it because
Kermit is like so clearly full-sized
like he doesn't look like a puppy and he
is an Italian great I mean it's like no
he's not growing I know in the person
probably just like a 13 year old that
was like I'll be like a 9 is he gonna
yes is it gonna get any bigger is he
full size couple it's probably such an
innocent question but the way we made
fun of it is no the way that I read it
and just like I just had this [ __ ]
like giggles like so many giggles so
funny people ask me that all the time in
person is he full size is he gonna grow
and I'm like that's a greyhound right
he's a baby he's a [ __ ] dog he's his
feet are like this big he's not a puppy
Yeah right nobody I think it was just
funny I just read it and you know that
now is the observance 9th Grove I think
that you should walk through them you
need to be watering your cerements you
need to be taking less water and for
yourself and putting some more on top of
your cerements while he's in the Sun
plant them the salmon the Sarah Matt
Serra Matt Phair Matt Farah Matt all
right are we done here I think I don't
know what do you see how you feeling
good yeah yeah it was fun yeah I think
it was good thank you for watching
everyone we'll be back with another
podcast but yeah and now we are gonna go
collect all tailwater into land and put
it on there Sam we love you guys
subscribe we'll be back soon